35 mil millones de euros Este es el
gasto total del presupuesto para el año
2023 presentado Este martes por el
gobierno italiano un presupuesto que
prevé mayormente un gasto destinado a
ayudar familias y empresas con unos
21.000 millones de euros para limitar el
impacto de la inflación y del aumento
del precio de la energía el gobierno
italiano facilitará créditos Fiscales
que pasarán del 40 al 45% para las
empresas con mayor gasto energético se
destinarán 4.200 millones de euros a
reducir los impuestos de los
trabajadores también se anunció que el
IVA baja del 10 al 5% para todos los
productos de primera necesidad para la
primera infancia y los productos de
higiene femenina y para las familias con
escasos recursos económicos se usarán
500 millones de euros para bajar el
precio de una serie de productos de
primera necesidad Igualmente se añade un
mes más del permiso a las madres
trabajadoras después del parto que
pasará de ser retribuido del 30 al 80
por ciento otro capítulo importante las
pensiones se anunció un nuevo plan para
anticipar la jubilación que permitirá a
los italianos dejar de trabajar con 41
años de contribuciones y 62 años de edad
según estimaciones esta medida afectaría
a unas 50.000 personas aquí en Italia